last time we talked about how you can
secure your service accounts by
understanding the iam roles associated
with them
one of the roles i mentioned was a
service account key admin a role that
lets you create service account keys
that could then be used to allow users
to authenticate
as a service account from outside google
cloud that sounds kind of risky doesn't
it
today i'll go over a few fundamentals of
managing service account keys
so that you can reduce the risk and keep
your service account safe
and in case you want to minimize using
service account keys i'll show you how
in some cases you can authenticate
as a service account without having to
create or distribute keys at all
let's get to it i'm going to tell you
what's what with service count keys and
impersonation
before we dive into service account keys
let's talk about the security
implication of using them
for users that already have access to
your project there aren't
any special roles that they need to use
service account keys to act as them
that means that any user in your
project's ian policy
that has access to that key will be able
to utilize the corresponding service
account to access
apis and services this can be especially
problematic
if the service account has broad access
to your project
and on top of that once you distribute a
key it can be difficult to make sure
that it doesn't fall into the wrong
hands
for this reason it's a best practice to
rotate keys as often as possible
rotating keys is a process of swapping
out old keys for new ones and then
deactivating the old ones it's a simple
three-step process
first you generate new keys for each of
your service accounts
then you replace the old key with a new
one wherever it's being used
and last you delete the old ones so they
don't work anymore
so how do we generate new service
account keys if you're using google
cloud console
or the gcloud cli you have two ways of
creating a key for your service account
uploading your own or having google
generate it for you
if you want to upload your own key
you'll use gcloud i am
surface counts keys upload followed by
the file with your public key
and the iam account flag to indicate a
service account you want to use it for
you won't need to upload the private key
it's up to you to keep it secured
it'll be used to access your project as
a service account
to have google generate a new key pair
you'll use gcloud
i am service accounts keys create
followed by the output file you want to
save your private key to
and the i am account flag to indicate
the service account you want the key for
this will immediately save the private
key to the file indicated
this will be the only time the private
key is provided to you
remember it's your responsibility to
keep the private key safe
and secure the output file when you have
google cloud generate a key will look
like this
it's a json object with fields like
project id
private key id and private key itself
the service account email and id
and more note that the key in this
format can be used for running gcloud
commands
if you want to use a key to access any
cloud resources using the rest api
you can generate a key by sending an
http post request to the corresponding
api url
along with your access token that will
turn a private key
the format of the json you get with this
method is a bit different
we recommend that you just use the same
method you're going to use for future
api calls
otherwise you have to edit the key to
match the desired format
when you want to delete an old key
you'll need the keys id
gcloud im service counts keys list
followed by the service account will
spit out the keys that currently exist
for that service account
by key id along with the date of
creation and the date of expiration
with that you can delete it with gcloud
i am service counts keys delete followed
by the key id from the previous output
the old key is now unusable to
authenticate as your service account
but if you replace it in all the places
that you need it to work that shouldn't
be a problem
if you need a way for users to access
service accounts but you're concerned
about having to manage service account
keys
there is some good news for some use
cases a key
really isn't required instead users can
create
short-lived service account credentials
short-lived service account credentials
have a limited lifetime with durations
of just a few hours or shorter
they also generate less risk than
long-lived credentials such as service
account keys
a user of the service account token
creator role on a service account will
be able to take
advantage of short-lived credentials for
example
they can generate an oauth2 access token
for the service account to access the
google cloud rest api
as a service account additionally a user
of this role can use the impersonate
service account flag on any gcloud
command
to run it as a service account no keys
required
depending on your organizational needs
you could reduce or even eliminate the
use of service account keys
and in effect reduce the attack surface
of your project
by understanding service account keys
and implementing a solid rotation
process for them
you will be taking some major steps in
securing your project service accounts
if you're able to cut out keys where you
can and take advantage of short-lived
service account credentials
then that's even better we've covered a
lot of ground in the last four episodes
about service accounts
hopefully by now you've got a pretty
good idea of what they are
and how to best manage them in your
google cloud project
next time we'll dive a little deeper in
an extended episode where we'll see
service accounts in action
see you soon
you